first kisses are awkward enough but
imagine having yours onscreen stars from
your favorite movies Nickelodeon Disney
Channel and Netflix shows did just that
keep watching to the end to discover
which star ended up marrying her first
kiss Michael now I know I can honestly
trust you with all my heart
Elle Fanning revealed that her first
kiss was on screen that was when she was
13 in the movie ginger and Rosa the
actor explained that the director Sally
Porter had a spidey sense even though L
tried to fool her into thinking that she
was experienced Sally knew it was her
first kiss and years later the director
revealed to Elle that she used the very
first take because it was so authentic l
thinks that her first kiss peed on
screen for eternity is a bit
embarrassing but sweet did I tell you
I've decided to be a poet
Al's big sister Dakota also had her
first ever kiss on screen it was for
Sweet Home Alabama and she was just
seven years old the actor she kissed was
ten years old
Dakota was playing a young Reese
Witherspoon in the first scene of the
movie Dakota described it as very
nerve-wracking after each take she would
slowly turn away and wipe her mouth off
her real-life first kiss was when she
was 14 and it was in her driveway and
that was it it was like against like my
mom's car like in the driveway Victoria
Justice had her first ever kiss on
screen during the second episode of The
Suite Life of Zack and Cody
her character Rebecca initiates the kiss
with Cody played by Cole Sprouse it's a
cute little peck on the lips and at
rocks Cody's world but how did Victoria
feel about it reminiscing about the
scene the actor said it was filmed in
front of a live audience and that was
cool she also said that she's still good
friends with Cole which is adorable
that's the only reason why I'm doing the
pageant
speaking of cole sprouse Selena Gomez
had her first ever kiss with Cole's
brother Dylan on The Suite Life of Zack
and Cody but she wished it was with Cole
instead because she had a huge crush on
him
so when she guest-starred on the show
but kissed his twin instead Selena
described it as one of the worst days of
her life she says she messed up the
timing because she closed her eyes a
little too early and ended up missing
half of his lip
so she was relieved that Dylan was an
awesome guy when it came to the most
Awkward kiss in the world cool and guess
what that awkward kiss on screen was
Dylan's first smooch too
when answering questions about his first
Dylan opened up about that kiss he
recalled he wasn't very successful with
women for a long time when commenting on
his first kiss being on set and with
Selena Gomez he said that was
interesting then skew fourthly father's
house tomorrow night in real life Cole
Sprouse has been linked to his Riverdale
co-star Lily Reinhart since 2016 and
Lily is yet another actor who had her
first kiss on screen she revealed it was
on the set of a movie blue describes it
as horrifying but not because her mom
was on set they're super close so that
wasn't awkward for the mother-daughter
duo but it was definitely strange
because Lily shared her first kiss with
an older guy in the end though Lily
didn't really have to try that hard it
just happened so that was a relief and
she was just happy to have it over with
I guess I just feel a lot better about
things
mili Bobbi Brown's first ever time
kissing a boy was on the set of stranger
things her character 11 is kissed by
Mike played by Finn Wolford she revealed
she was very nervous about kissing her
co-star he said that he kissed a lot but
Millie wasn't sure that was quite true
they both hyped themselves up about it
even though it was just a fact they
wanted to be sure they'd have fresh
breath after they completed the scene
and Millie walked away and said kissing
sucks
Mille wasn't the only one to have her
first kiss on the set of stranger things
her co-star Caleb McLaughlin also did
when his character Lucas kissed
Sadie sings character max Caleb admitted
he was already feeling weird about it
and the pressure built up even more when
Millie and Finn finished filming their
kiss scene
Sadie wasn't a big fan of the unscripted
kiss because it was done in front of
hundreds of extras and even her own mom
god this this is so stupid you accept
the risk
saoirse ronan was around 11 or 12 years
old when she experienced her first kiss
and it was on-screen it was for her
first feature film I could never be your
woman the actor revealed that she asked
the director Amy Heckerling for advice
Saoirse also admitted that she was a
proper prude they had to do about eight
takes of the three-second kiss so she
joked that she was a phenomenal kisser
by the end what's shocking miranda
cosgrove first kiss took place on the
set of iCarly her character Carly kissed
Freddie moments before his mother walked
in and ruined the moment that episode
which is called I saved her life is
actually Miranda's favorite when asked
what it was like to kiss nathan kress
who plays Freddy Miranda said he was a
little strange she explained that
kissing him felt a little off because
she'd known him for such a long time and
he become like a brother to her so I'm
gonna get my bags and head downstairs
tyler posey shared his first kiss with
miley cyrus when he was just 9 years old
he was working on the medical drama
doc was Miley's dad Billy Ray Cyrus and
in the scene Miley leans over to give
him a peck on the cheek to say thanks
this was in her pre Hannah Montana days
the two bonded on set and we're known
for being goofy Tyler said Miley was
really loud sweet and funny a really
cool kid they bonded so well they became
a couple for two years until the ripe
old age of eleven just thanks Ariel
winter had her first kiss while filming
a scene from Modern Family as Alex the
middle child in the dumphy family Ariel
received a kiss on the track from a
co-star when she was 17 years old the
character's parents were all watching
from the bleachers okay that's enough I
think I think we can dial it back
Mayim Balak and Johnny Galecki have
starred together for a long time on Big
Bang Theory but they actually go way
back to the 1990s when Johnny
guest-starred on Mayim show blossom in
an interview with Conan O'Brien Johnny
says that they first shared their first
onscreen kiss together when they were 14
but it was an even bigger milestone for
ma'am
she admitted it might have been her
first real-life kiss also Kay Panabaker
had her first kiss with Zac Efron on
Summerland she was 13 at the time and he
was 16 she admitted that it was totally
embarrassing in front of the crew
because they were all like her dad's
even though the situation was a little
strange kay says that Zac was so nice
and so sweet and he still is it was the
first onscreen kiss and he was very
nervous
too because she was young Zac wanted to
make Kay feel as comfortable as possible
what a gentleman I mean that something
never have to worry about
Keke Palmer shared her first ever kiss
with Corbin Bleu while filming the
Disney Channel original movie jump in
Kiki was 12 years old at the time the
actor admitted she was very very nervous
to be kissing the first person outside
of her family
dad made it really scary for her
fortunately that tied in with how her
character was feeling too they filmed
the scene about 20 times and she says
Corbin was so sweet about it
Connie much josh hutcherson had his
first onscreen kiss long before he was
cast as Peeta in the Hunger Games
franchise Josh was 11 at the time and
acting in the movie little Manhattan he
says it was a horrible first kiss
because there was a crew of fifty people
watching the actor described it as the
most non real non intimate first kiss he
could possibly have had his mom was
there and surprised him by flying his
dad in to help support him because he
was so nervous and her wreck for that
scene did I do it right I don't know
I've absolutely nothing to compare it to
[Music]
Kirsten Dunst had her first kiss on
screen with none other than Brad Pitt
she was 11 years old when she filmed
interview with the vampire and Brad was
18 years older than her at the time she
called the kiss gross because Brad was
like an older brother to her and after
25 years she still sticks by that
comment she thought it would have been
so much creepier if she'd actually
enjoyed the kiss but she added that Brad
and her co-star Tom Cruise were so sweet
to her
[Music]
Macaulay Culkin and Anna Chlumsky
charmed audiences with their
relationship in the movie my girl which
featured both of their first kisses they
won the best kiss award at the 1992 MTV
Movie Awards when she accepted the award
Anna sweetly said gee my first kiss and
I get an award but Macaulay who was 11
at the time was not into it when talking
about the kiss he said it was like 15
takes all angles each Macaulay went on
to date Mila Kunis who also had her
first kiss on-screen but not with him
the story of Mila Kunis first kiss
borders on a fairy tale because it was
with Ashton Kutcher for that 70 show way
back in 1998 she thought Ashton was so
cute and her crush on him made her feel
so nervous and uncomfortable the
producers gave her perfume to spritz
herself with to help mask her nerves and
it did the trick the couple started
dating years later in 2012 they got
married in 2015 and now have two
children a few years after their
onscreen kiss
Ashton found out he was the first guy
Mila had ever kissed he admitted to
being so glad he didn't know that at the
time as it would have been too much
pressure he said he was so nervous and
thought Mila acted so cool like she'd
done it a thousand times which one of
these first kiss story surprised you the
most and which couples do you hope to
see together in the future
tell us in the comments please give us a
big thumbs up and remember to hit that
subscribe button to be the first to
watch our latest videos thanks for
watching